[Applause]
the middle ages
a time when you were more likely to die
on the toilet than take a bath
and now you're going there with an
educational mission
it's up to you now let's show the middle
ages how it's done
but would you be tried as a witch
could you cure all diseases
or would you accidentally create a new
pandemic
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you brought modern technology
to the middle ages
it's easy to write off the middle ages
as a backward time for hygiene and
technology
while you might think the church and
science were at odds with each other
nothing could be further from the truth
some religious leaders thought
scientific advancements celebrated
humanity's divine creator
so
if you time traveled back into the
european middle ages with your cell
phone the technology within it might be
embraced by this developing society
but
how would you recharge it
excuse me anyone here got a charger
historians refer to the years between
500 and 1500 ce as the middle ages
but if you traveled back to this time to
europe your presence and technology
could fast forward the era into a
different form of enlightenment
so
don't worry those torches aren't for you
i don't think
and if you want to make this world a
better place
you could start in the bathroom
in this time the upper class built
toilets called guard robes
these devices
dropped everything out the side of the
castles and into a moat below
oh jeez launch your step
while china was making advancements in
toilet paper
european society was waist deep in
well waste
this unhealthy environment created
bacteria that spread diseases like
cholera which could kill you within
hours
introducing toilet paper and a sewer
system made of bricks would prevent many
early deaths
but what about other diseases
well better hygiene technology wouldn't
cure everything
smallpox was a deadly disease that
killed nearly 33 percent of those
infected
and we didn't invent a vaccine for it
until 1796
bringing that vaccine back to the middle
ages
may not work as well as you expect
though
because you would run out of it and you
wouldn't have a way to make more
but dr edward jenner inventor of the
smallpox vaccine found that milkmaids
infected by cow pox became immune to
this disease
so
if you brought back cow pox and used it
to infect people
you could create an early immunity to
one of the world's deadliest viruses
while a cow pox pandemic could take many
lives
it would kill much fewer people than
smallpox
and maybe you should wear a mask for the
first few weeks so you don't spread any
viruses from the future
okay now that you've healed europe of a
life-threatening disease
it's time to connect it
while the discovery of electricity dates
back to the ancient greeks
this concept is still just an abstract
thought in the middle ages
although you could show the europeans
how to use the materials they have to
create the world's first electrical grid
you could teach people to take copper
smelt it down and meticulously pound it
by hand into wire
then using magnets you could create an
electrical charge and direct it wherever
you need it
you would still have to teach people how
to build light bulbs solar panels and
engines but you've given them the basis
of a new age of connectivity
the printing press could become
electrified hundreds of years earlier
and images and text could be transmitted
worldwide
knowledge wouldn't be restricted only to
those who can afford it
but even with an electrical grid
could you use your cell phone
during the middle ages people used a
popular device called an astrolabe that
could tell the time give your location
and even predict your horoscope
introducing handheld mobile devices
would make this hanging status symbol
obsolete
but would this advancement just turn
into another boredom killer
what would you bring back to the middle
ages let us know in the comments
with the electrical systems in place you
can finally recharge your phone
not to mention your time machine
the changes you made would speed up
humanity's development
and the future you grew up in
may not even happen
so what if you took this time machine
and went one billion years into the
future
well charge up that battery for the flux
capacitor
because that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you